hi everyone again and uh this time we
will have alexander molech to present um
uh a topic on modeling and the aliotoric
and apps epistemic uncertainty using
cancer flow and tensorflow probability
trust me i used to be able to pronounce
it right
and
alexander
is the author of sunday ai papers a
linking weekly michael block on the
latest advancement in nlp casual
inference and more alright alexander
yeah you can present now thank you very
much
great thank you for the introduction
over thank you so much
hi everyone my name is alexander mollak
today's uh today's talk topic is uh
modeling uncertainty
in neural networks using tensorflow and
tensorflow probability
um
let me just check if my if i can change
my slides okay so let's start with a
brief agenda we will start first with a
quick uh motivation why even bother why
to model uncertainty then
we'll look at those two types of
uncertainty that we have in the title so
alliatoric and epistemic uncertainty we
include we'll include a couple of simple
examples then we'll jump to a more
practical aspect and we'll look at
tensorflow probability library
and then we'll start modeling so you can
say we will start the party right so
we'll look how to
uh how to model alliatoric uncertainty
how to model epistemic uncertainty both
using tensorflow probability and
tensorflow and then at the end i will
show you also a simple trick how we can
um model epistemic uncertainty using
planes uh plain pencil flow and at the
end hopefully we will have a couple of
minutes for a q a session
now before we start a five five
sentences about me uh currently i work
at lingaro as innovation lead and
machine learning researcher i'm mostly
interested in natural language
processing probabilistic modelling and
causal inference and as horrible
mentioned i'm the author of sunday ai
papers which is a linkedin based micro
blog where every week on sunday i
review a couple of
most recent recent papers
outside machine learning i'm also
interested in complex systems psychology
and neuroscience and it's a part of my
academic background and privately i
enjoy traveling with my wife running i
appreciate good vegan food and love to
learn languages
at some point we'll have a notebook here
in this presentation if you want to
follow on call up for instance you can
use this repository and you will find
the materials there
so it's pi data global 2021
and my github name is
and d a-l-x-a-n-d-r a l okay so it's my
name and uh surname without vowels
okay so why model uncertainty why we why
even bother
let's uh start with some practical
examples first imagine that you built a
gas price prediction system you want to
predict gas prices at some points in
in time
um this is a contrived example because
you know gas prices might be a random
walk might be hard to predict and so on
but let's imagine we can do it somehow
and from a classical deep learning model
regression model you will get a point a
point estimate
now you might ask okay i have some point
estimate for a given time point but what
is the variance against around this
estimate so you might be interested in
assessing how much this uh
how much this point estimate may vary
right so
in other words is a question about
confidence intervals another question
you can uh you can ask yourself is that
if you predict a couple of points in
time ahead in time
then you will get some kind of a tragic
trajectory right and you might be
thinking okay
now
there's one thing is this variance
around those points but another point is
how correct this trajectory itself is
right and this is something that we'll
look at uh that we'll look at today a
little bit a little bit later the second
um
second case is uh
is a case of medical diagnosis system
uh
you might have built a system like this
or maybe you're working on a system like
this and then the system at some point
goes to production and predicts cancer
diagnosis in inpatient in patient x and
the soft max score for this diagnosis is
0.9 so we
can conceptualize this
as
a multi-class classification problem and
we might uh ask a question how sure are
we that this diagnosis is is correct
so if it's both nine maybe you have
three possible diagnosis in your system
and this is what you get so most people
naively would say that
the diagnosis a we can be pretty sure
about about its correctness but now you
can start
modeling uncertainty in your system as
well and you might get something like
this where the area of this uh blue
rectangle are confidence intervals
around the
um around your softmax scores
so this is you might you might ask like
what how come right but this is uh this
is a possible example and i will show
you one um actual example from a real
world system where a very similar thing
happened
okay
now let's
talk briefly about those two types of
uncertainty so we talked about eleatoric
and epistemic uncertainty
what does it actually mean
so alliatoric uncertainty the name
comes from uh latin word elia
it doesn't have anything to do with
hebrew word aliyah if you know hebrew
its original meaning is a joint bone a
little bone that people
uh used to
as the ice right so they were just
throwing this and generating some random
outcomes so it's a very very early
version of a pseudorandom number
generator in a sense
another name for this kind of
uncertainty perhaps a simpler one is
data uncertainty
and it's uh
and we have this word data there because
this type of uncertainty is inherently
related to the data generating process
so one of the examples that you could
think of here
is uh coin tossing if your point is fair
your perfect model
will
will give you a
uniform distribution over both outcomes
that we can get here
but still and this is the last point on
the slide
this type of uncertainty cannot be
reduced by adding more data
so even if you have a perfect model of a
coin of a fair coin
it doesn't help you it
adding more data won't help you in
predicting another
the outcome of another of another task
so this is data uncertainty the second
type of uncertainty is epistemic
uncertainty uh the name comes from from
a greek word epistemi
which stands for knowledge or
understanding it was a word used by
early philosophers extensively like
aristotle and plato
another name for this type of
uncertainty
again a simpler perhaps a simpler name
is model uncertainty and this type of
uncertainty might be reduced by adding
more data because this is uncertainty of
our model uh parameters and this
uncertainty might be reduced if we add
more data from the same distribution
okay let's uh jump to something more
practical now and let's think about
tensorflow probability so how the
library that will help us modeling all
those concepts
tensorflow probability is a library that
is separate from core tensorflow
but it's a part of a tensorflow
ecosystem and it smoothly integrates
with both tensorflow and tf keras
it's a comprehensive library with 16 sub
modules
and today in the context of
modeling uncertainty in neural networks
we'll only focus on two of them
namely tfp distributions and tfp layers
so how do we import this we just say
tensorflow probability we
conventionally input this as tfb
and then those two sub modules that i
mentioned so distributions submodule and
layer submodules are conventionally
um assigned to an alias variable which
is tfd for distributions and pfpl for
for tensorflow probability layers okay
so now we'll go and see some code
you can follow using this link
great so so then let's jump to the let's
jump to the code
yeah
and let's run this cell so here we are
running numpy we are importing numpy
tensorflow tfp
we are assigning those two uh submodules
to those convenience variables and let's
start with something similar so
basically distributions distributions is
something that is the most basic
building block here let's build a normal
distribution with mean 100 and standard
deviation of 15
and let's see what we've got here we've
got an object
of a class dfb distribution is normal it
has two um it has two attributes bad
shape and event shape
uh
they are important but for the sake of
today's presentation we won't pay too
much attention to them
and let's see at some methods that
distributions in tfp have so first
sample
okay we can just sample it this will
return a tf tensor
uh we can
transfer it we can transform it into a
numpy array using mf numpy and we can
look at the samples
do they look normal well maybe not very
normal but more or less normal let's say
okay another set of methods that are
very very important and will be very
important for us are dot probe and dot
lock problem
these two methods
return
uh
pdf values the first one returns pdf
values of your distribution so here we
will say normal.prop
and the second one returns log pdf
values so these are not probabilities at
least in case of continuous variables
this is something
it's worth remembering but these are pdf
values right so they might be in some
cases larger than larger than one
so let's see how this works
uh we got
uh the pdf value is the highest for for
for 100 which is our mean that's as
expected as
and as you can see
we have those symmetries here when we
move one and two standard deviations
below and above the mean
and the same is true for the log method
right so this value is the highest one
and this is the minimum of our normal
distribution okay let's start with our
let's start with our
uh with our party modeling party so we
start with modeling eleatoric
uncertainty and we'll use tfp layers
another module
let's start with generating some data it
will be a linear data set
just like this with some gaussian noise
and of standard with standard deviation
of 0.35 so let's generate this data and
let's look at the scatter plot so this
is our data set and now let's build a
simple model the simple model will be
just a linear regression so we have one
dense layer
with one uh one neuron and without any
activation function mean squared error
as our loss and optimizer very simple
one just as stochastic gradient descent
we'll train this for 100 epochs predict
and we'll plot our regression
line
okay
so this is our regression line is it
perfect i don't know but i think it's
reasonable well
and now let's try to do the same thing
but adding this alliatoric now layer
okay
so
just to uh just to
uh remind you what eliatoric uncertainty
stands for it's it's the type of
uncertainty that is inherent to the data
generating process so if we look at this
we have some point estimates on this
line and this is the best fit line
but here there is some variability
around this line so we will try to model
this
so now we have this dense layer as in
our linear regression but instead of
just one neuron we'll add two neurons
here
why because this dense layer won't be a
output layer for for us
it will be a layer that will
parameterize a normal distribution and
we have independent normal here and this
normal distribution
will have two parameters
mean and
standard deviation
so now because this is the last layer
that we have here and this layer will
return a distribution itself
we cannot use a mean squared error
anymore and we need our custom
and we need our custom
loss function for this
and for this problem uh computing a
negative log likelihood is a good idea
uh as any
you know loss function in tensorflow or
keras it it takes white through and wipe
red so it's two objects
and white red is now
this which means an output of this layer
which is a distribution
so
we take this distribution we use a log
probe method of this distribution and we
put our y through so our pred our
training data
inside this distribution and we add
a minus side because we are we want to
minimize instead of maximizing
and yeah and let's train it so this loss
function will
will assess how good
a model of
the our training data the distribution
our distribution is okay
and now let's see how it works and now
because we are learning distribution we
have a generated model this generative
model can not only make a prediction for
us but can also generate data
so this is uh the training data in blue
and red in red you have samples from our
land train distribution
and now we can also
build confidence intervals for this
right
so of course in case of in the case of
linear regression you could also get
those confidence intervals uh from from
a classical
classical model
but these consoles continuous intervals
will also work for any non-linear
problem whatever whatever you want
want to do and i will show you an
example in the at the end
okay so now we're jumping into epistemic
epistemic uncertainty
and we'll use uh variational inference
to do this
uh epistemic uncertainty as we discussed
this before
is a type of uncertainty
a type of model uncertainty where we
want to model uncertainty over the
parameters of our model right so here's
one example of
how this can be how this can be pictured
on your left you can see a classical
neural network where each wave is a is a
point estimate
and on your right you see a
a neural network that models epistemic
uncertainty and each weight here is a
distribution right so
before we just had a distribution at the
end here in the prediction layer the
last layer now we have distributions
over all our weights inside the neural
network but the prediction will be a
point estimate again
so to do this we'll use a method that is
called base by back prop that it has
been introduced um in 2015 uh by
blundell
and we we are using a
an estimate of
base theorem and approximation of base
theorem to to compute our posterior
and there are three basic steps uh to do
this so first we pick a prior density
over our weights
which is here
and then we use data to determine the
likelihood of data given those weights
and then we are trying to estimate the
posterior finally using these quantities
and we'll use um
elbow or evidence lower bound
to do this
we don't have time in this talk to go
into theory but if you're interested in
this under this link you will find some
information
here you can find some information about
kl divergence um android
parameterization trick which are
building blocks of this whole method for
variational base okay so let's get back
to our linear data let's plot it
now we are plotting two data sets as you
can see because epistemic uncertainty is
something that we can
reduce by using more data and we want to
see this so that's why we generated two
data sets
now the whole process is a little bit
more complex than it was for eleatoric
uncertainty because we need to define
prior and posterior functions explicitly
and then pass them to the tfpl dense
variation so the structure of this code
is as follows inside we have a keras
model
that returns a distribution this
distribution a prior this the prior
distribution is not trainable it's just
normal
multivariate normal distribution
and then in posterior model again we
have a normal distribution this time
it's trainable and this layer here
before
returns a trainable variable that will
be used to parameterize this
distribution here
okay
so
yeah so let's um
let's see how this works
we'll build an ele the aliatoric model
now so we'll use a pfpl dense
variational layer as we mentioned before
and this layer has some similarities to
the classical dense layers that we use
in tensorflow it has one neuron because
it's a simple linear regression problem
the input shape is one-dimensional again
we have one-dimensional input and then
we have something that
something new so we have make prior and
make posterior functions and we just
pass our functions but we don't call
them here we just pass him here
and then we need to add some waiting as
well
this is say waiting for uh
cool back labor like the divergence part
of our objective elbow that has to be
normalized if you want it to be unbiased
unfortunately we don't have time to go
into theoretical details of this but you
can find some information on the
internet and i will provide you with
some useful links and here we are saying
that we will
compute the coolback labeler diverge
divergence
um
approximately so we could also in our
case said set this to true
and this would analytically compute the
kl divergence uh
between those prior and posterior
distributions but we will set it to
false because it's more interesting and
more universal
okay so let's train this model
we'll train two models one for 100
observations a smaller data set and
another one for one thousand
thousand observations for the
the bigger data set
and we'll also plot our loss
function
and when it's training i will also tell
you one one more thing that i think uh
is interesting so here again we as ls as
the loss function we are using mean
squared error why is that because this
distribution
you know
this distribution estimates uncertainty
over the weights but not over the output
right so output is an is again
um is again a scalar value scalar value
so the loss function as you can see that
the loss function for the smaller data
set is more wiggly and the one for a
larger data set is
smoother
and now let's do 15 predictions so now
our model has weights
as distributions modeled as
distributions so each time that we make
a prediction using this model
we will get slightly different estimates
okay
and we will see this here
that's why we're doing this 15 times
because we want to see those estimates
and as you can see the model trained on
a smaller data set gives us much more
uncertainty when it comes to those line
parameters right both
um
both
the intercept and slope right while for
one thousand uh for one thousand data
points
our uncertainty is much much
slower now what we can also do
much much smaller i wanted to say sorry
uh now what we can also do we can
model both types of uncertainty and
build a fully uh fully probabilistic
model
and i will just show you the
architecture for this we won't train it
because it would take too long
here we have tfpl variational again then
we have another variation now because
this case will be
non-linear so we want to
model some non-linearity here and then
we have at the end
again again an independent normal
as a as a
as our output distribution
so let me now switch back to the
presentation and i will show you uh what
would be the outcome of this so for this
data set this nonlinear data set uh this
is something that we would get so you
can see that
we have many red lines here hopefully
you can see this
and those many red lines are many
different possible trajectories that
come from our weight distributions
inside the model and these green lines
they mark a plus minus
50
plus minus two uh standard deviation
or all 95 percent confidence intervals
you can see that for each prediction we
have a separate line now as well right
so we have different trajectory for the
for the for the for the line for the
mean line but also our confidence
intervals are moving and this is a fully
probabilistic
model
and i promise you at the end
that i will show you also a
a little trick how to
how to model
epistemic uncertainty using plain
tensorflow so
this is a very simple trick you could
say
surprisingly surprisingly simple
um
and i will show you here a code from one
of the projects that i was working on
some time ago
this is a classification problem as
opposed to what we've seen what we've
seen before
and as you can see we have only dense
layers here and drop out layers here
and then
this model would give us just a regular
set of predictions
but to
switch it to
uh or transform it and transform it to a
model that that models epistemic
uncertainty
we can do one simple thing so when we
are generating predictions we just set
training to true
start to interrupt but uh we still have
five minutes before the end of the
session yes yes i'm aware of this i have
my my clock so so it's like i will just
finish the slide and it will be time for
our q and a
session
great
so so we are just setting training to
true which leaves dropout layers active
and we can make
1000 predictions maybe and get a
distribution now so as you can see
uh
in this case the model predicted
correctly the
true true label which was zero here is
the probability predicted by a regular
model the red uh this red rectangle is a
posterior distribution and the black
line is the mean of the posterior but
here in this case we had
we had another prediction the true label
was one
model predicted something really close
to one so it could be probably like 0.97
but as you can see the distribution is
very very broad so it's it comes from
zero to one so the uncertainty here was
really huge and the mean is much much
lower than
the probability predicted by the
soft max score here okay so that's uh
that's all
and
now we have a couple of minutes uh for
questions
uh thank you alexander for the
presentation we have a few questions but
we only have three minutes even though
this is
the last
um presentation of the session so let's
see if we can wrap them up quickly the
first question is related to the patch
related
of the
okay let's see of the probability
density function uh jan would like to
know uh the purpose of the session
related to probability density function
ah so the purpose of describing this in
the in the presentation was that this
method that evaluates pdf for a given
input
uh is something that is useful for
training uh training the models then
right if we have this probabilistic
layer as the as the as the last layer in
our model then we can compute a log
likelihood of of the data uh thanks to
having this uh distribution and and and
and the ability
uh to evaluate the pdf or log pdf
hopefully this answered the question and
hopefully i understood it well
okay so the last question i think we can
all right uh we have two similar
questions
which is about tensorflow
comparison between tensorflow and pi mc
when would you prefer tensorflow over pi
mc uh
eo is guessing that when you are testing
for a longer model on the same account
can one does um hierarchical modeling in
tensorflow
yeah so uh
so the first question was
when would you prefer one over the other
i think if you are working on on a deep
learning models and you build your code
in tensorflow and so on then then tfp is
something that very very smoothly
integrates with tensorflow
and that's the main reason i would say
um
the second question about hierarchical
models i i think you can build them as
well there are 16 sub modules there you
have generalized linear models
there's really a lot uh a lot of stuff
going on in intensive slow probability
and and actually i think everything that
can be done in pi mc3 uh can be done in
tensorflow probability as well that
would be my best bet for now
okay so one minute so one last question
uh how is the express um from mateo how
is this preciously modeled at hysteric
functionality you have shown us
different from the simple simply
resampling of the original predicting a
regression line and relative
confidence interval and then measure
epistemic uncertainty by looking at the
variability in them
yeah so so this bootstrapping part i
think that's this is something that um
that would show
at the end right that we've shot so
shown that we've shown in the end when
you can
just bootstrap your um
your predictions but then you need this
dropout right otherwise without dropout
your model is not probabilistic so draw
so this dropout of monte carlo dropout
as it's called
is a way of approximating epistemic some
uncertainty
hopefully this answers your um your
question
okay uh thank you very much uh and
alexander thank you for participating
and all the other presenters thank you
for participating in pi data global and
that's the end of uh not just this
presentation but this session
as well hopefully everyone enjoys it and
yeah
so yeah see you again next session
thanks a lot again
thank you so much bye